wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
hallo frau entschuldigung wartest du
schon lange
na ja wir haben noch zeit warum tier
dankeschön
ich bin in letzter zeit ziemlich
gestresst weil einige kollegen krank
sind wirklich nur in letzter zeit
bedanken ist es eigentlich noch machen
ich finde du solltest einfach mal
weniger arbeiten könnte es auch mal nein
sagen ja ich bin heute auch gestresst
wegen dem termin
ich weiß immer noch nicht ob ich das
kind überhaupt will sebastian meint ich
muss mich endlich entscheiden das stimmt
aber zum monats malina du schaffst das
du kannst auch du kannst auch eine
beratung machen vielleicht hilft das
okay aber nur wenn du einen yogakurs
machst du etwas gegen den stress zu tun
haben nur wenn du mit kommst du bist
auch nur ein mensch vergisst es nicht
nur mensch ist eine an dem auch der
heute untersucht werden soll
das ja ist okay lass uns einfach
reingehen und dann schauen wir weiter ja
ja ich wollte nicht